concert posters so-called gig posters
for legendary bands they have bold
original motifs and all of them are
handmade silkscreen prints they're
designed by Lars P krauser a 45 year old
poster artist based in Dresden when it
comes to gig posters he's the go-to guy
first of all I only make a poster if the
band is any good and full artistic
control is mine not the band's if the
artist has plenty of creative freedom
and the band accepts that you'll get a
better poster usually bands managers or
agents contact krauser to Commission a
poster bands may request a certain style
but krauser is free to choose the motif
ultimately bands must authorize the
poster because they have the right to
their name and reactions may vary
sometimes they shriek for joy when they
see the poster I've made but one time
I'll keep the band's name a secret they
rip the posters to shreds and use them
as price tanks that can happen to
krauser draws inspiration from the
poster artwork in 1980s America it
developed as an answer to the high gloss
rock posters of the time it's a growing
scene that comes together at music
festivals Hamburg art collector Ralph
Kruger was the first to bring these gig
posters to Europe he initiated the first
meeting of poster artists in 2006 if you
look inside the office there are so many
different kinds of artists with such
individual styles some have an affinity
with drawing some with collages other
with graphic art in coefficient but I
combed in the mid-nineties Krueger
discovered the silk screens of Franco's
ik a pioneer of geek poster artwork
that's Muma phages I love cars as colors
and his ideas he plucks motifs from
everywhere and he uses them to make very
caustic witty commentary there what's
fake here no you come and tell it
krauser's works are similarly
provocative humorous and
Roenick he creates one or two posters
per month in limited editions of no more
than about a hundred after drawing the
motif he prints layer after layer of
color
then the posters have to dry
the screen needs cleaning and a new
photo exposure after every layer
Krauser has made posters for the Eagles
of Death Metal several times the u.s.
band was playing in the Parisian butter
clan club when terrorists stormed the
building in November 2015 I made these
four shows that never happened there was
supposed to be gigs in Cologne and
Munich and Bremen but they were
cancelled after the attack so we
wondered what are we gonna do with the
posters these potentially we ended up
selling them and the proceeds were
donated to the victims families of
police bended most of krauser's posters
cost between 40 and 80 euros enough to
support himself
one more layer of color and this poster
for the Berlin Hamburg fashion label
half and deep will be ready
my neck Lena I'm quite pleased with the
half and deep my little doc rat the
colors harmonized the shades of blue
work well together this outline I have
just printed is drying it'll have a
stronger blue tone overall I'm very
happy with my creation I hope my client
will like it too the coolness of Hayden
you